so a lot of people say well how do I
find concerts so hard to know how do I
find like romantic comedies or whatever
it is that you're trying to find or
action thrillers without big-name cast
or whatever it is you're trying to do
and one of the things that is great and
free is Amazon you go to amazon.com and
you put in a movie that's likely you are
so let's say you found one movie that
was like yours and you don't know what
the other ones are put that and say you
want to buy it and then scroll down and
down at the bottom it says customers who
bought this movie also bought that movie
and you're going to see going along the
bottom of the page all these other
possible movies and a good number of
those are probably comps for you so
that's one sort of easy quick and dirty
way to begin to develop a database of
comparative titles for what you're
trying to do
you